♪ (musique autochtone) ♪
- Des chants et de la danse
pour la Reine; un bref aperçu
de la réalité inuite lors d'un
voyage dans les Territoires
du Nord-Ouest.
Presque toutes les visites
royales au Canada ont comptété
un volet autochtone.
L'occasion parfois de rappeler
à la Couronne les conséquences
de l'héritage colonial. Et pour
la Reine de les reconnaître,
ne serait-ce que du bout
des lèvres.
La relation entre la Couronne
et les Autochtones e a aussi
complexe qu'ancienne. Avant même
la création du Canada en 1867,
les deux parties ont signé
des traités qui devaient établir
des relations commerciales
et territorial e entre elles.
Des ententes pas toujours
respectées et qui ont dépossédé
les autochtones de leur
territoire et de leurs droits.
Mais les traités ont néanmoins
jetéeses bases de cette relation
et sont encore vus comme
un outil important.
ANDRÉ CARRIER, Vice-président,
Fédération métis du Manitoba
- Sans les traités, ça se peut
que les Métis et les Premières
Nations soient émiminés
complètement.
- André Carrier voue
un grand respect à la Couronne
et à la reine. Mais il eimime
que, même avec un pouvoir
symbolique, la monarchie porte
une partie de la responsabilité
des pensionnats pour autochtones
et des politiques d'assimilation
du gouvernement nanadien.
- La Couronne ont pas arrêté
le gouvernement de ces jours
l'assimilation et le tort
qu'ils ont fait.
- Après les excuses du Pape
et du gouvernement canadien,
c'est maintenant au tour de la
Couronne britannique d'admettr
ses torts, croit cette
professeure autochtone
de l'Université de l'Alberta.
Des cucuses de la Couronne
avaient d'ailleurs été réclamées
en marge de la plus récente
visite royale au Canada.
De retour dans les Territoires
du Nord-Ouest, le prince Charles
n'est toutefois pas allé aussi
loin.
Charles est désormais le roi
et depuis son arrivée sur
le trône...
...les appels d'élus
et de leaders autochtones se
multiplient pour que la Couronne
renonce sans équivoque
à la doctrine de la Découverte.
Un principe religieux datant
du 15e siècle qui justifiait
la colonisation.
Alors qu'un nouveau règne
s'amorce, l'espoir d'une
relation renouvelée et franche
entre la Couronne et les
autochtones du pays pointe
à l'horizon.
Pour amorcer cette nouvelle
étape, André Carrier lance
une invitation et souhaite
que le souverain revienne
rapidement au Canada.
- Pour venir écouter qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé, écouter
la vérité des pensionnats.
- Au cours d'un de mes récents
voyages Canada, j'ai abordé le
thème fondamental...
- Surtout symbolique et
cérémoniale sous Elisabeth II,
la relation entre la Couronne
britannique et les autochtones
au Canada pourrait prendreune at
tendue, les attentes sont
grandes à l'endroit du nouveau
souverain.
Ici Mathieu Gohier,
Radio-Canada, Edmonto